I assert that if you're not in the
present moment you're running a program
right and paying attention is being
present and it's a skill just like
anything else the more you practice it
the better you get at it and you know
when someone's present with you in your
life because they're paying attention to
you and you know when they're not
present with you because they're not
paying attention to you so where you
place your attention is where you place
your energy so if you have all of your
attention in the present moment you're
conserving a lot of energy to create
with if I'm talking to you and you're
thinking about where you're gonna go for
lunch and who you're going to go with
and how you're going to get there and
I'm talking to you you left the present
moment and your attention went to some
future and your energy will go down and
you won't be able to comprehend what I
said if you start thinking about what
you should have said at the staff
meeting three days ago and I'm talking
to you and your mind is back in the past
you're siphoning energy out of the
present moment into the past so people
are constantly siphoning their energy
into a familiar past or a predictable
future because that's where their
attention is and the stronger the
emotions that we feel to certain
problems and can conditions in our life
the more we pay attention to them so we
give our power away to our ex we give
our power way to that big problem and
that's Creative Energy that we should be
able to use to create a new future need
motivation Watch Attack 10 with believe
Nation hey it's Evan Carmichael and I
make these videos because in my first
business I quit on my business partner I
was making 300 bucks a month and I
didn't have the motivation to keep going
and the thing that got me through was
studying the stories of entrepreneurs
who've had massive success and I hope
that in sharing these stories with you
you find a motivation to keep going and
if I'm being honest I still need the
source for myself today too so today
let's learn from one of the best Joe
dispenza and my take on his top 10 rules
of success
enjoy
when a person's sitting in a meditation
and they're doing absolutely nothing
and it's eight o'clock in the morning
and their body for the last 10 years has
been going in traffic and getting angry
and frustrated in traffic and now
they're sitting in a meditation at eight
o'clock in the morning the body's going
to say hey you're off schedule I'm used
to suffering and getting angry here so
the body's gonna start looking for that
emotion and it's going to start
influencing the mind and you're going to
start getting images and and memories
just so you can feel that emotion like
now now the person's back in the past
but if they become aware
that they're siphoning energy out of the
present moment into the past and they
settle the body back down into the
present moment that's a victory
and those victories add up and you're
telling the body in that moment
that it's no longer the mind that you're
the mind and that's a victory and then
people get frustrated and they say I
can't meditate oh really well actually
you're doing it right that's actually
what medicine you're doing exactly what
you're supposed to be doing and all of a
sudden the body says well
it's 8 15 now this is when you normally
you know go get something to eat and you
have your coffee and your body's
starting to want to get up and do
something you become aware that your
body wants to get up and move and you're
in the meditation and you tell your body
uh-uh you bring it back to the present
moment and you settle it back down you
are training the animal that's a victory
now you're executing a will
that's greater than the program because
most people lose their free will to a
program now you're telling the body I'll
tell you when we get up not when you
want to get up you're not the mind I'm
the mind and that's a victory now we've
done the research on this
if you keep doing this and you stay with
it
sooner or later the body is going to
surrender to a new mind and when that
happens Sean
there's a liberation of energy the body
is freed from those habituations and
those emotions the bodies going from
particle to wave from matter to energy
and all of a sudden you're dialing down
the anger you're dialing down the
vigilance and the body now is being
conditioned to a new mind that is the
present moment and when you're in that
present moment something really amazing
happens you forget about you
all of a sudden you're not your face
you're not your culture you're not your
your marital status you're not your diet
you're not your your past you're
basically just an awareness you're in
the unknown and that is the perfect
place to create from so it turns out
that when people do this properly they
heal themselves of anxiety why because
they're no longer obsessing about some
future
when they find the present moment they
heal their from their depression because
they're not a bit hopeless and Powerless
in their past the body's conditioned now
and so then
when they overcome themselves in their
meditation
and they step out into their life they
are more present they can connect they
are more patient they are more loving
because they overcome the animal part of
themselves and the beauty behind that is
is that all of a sudden you're not
predictable all of a sudden something's
different about Sean he's he's not I'm
noticing he's not behaving the same way
you're out of the known right you're in
the unknown and all of a sudden people
is no longer what you're saying to them
is who you are they're just kind of
scratching their head going hey he looks
like he's really happy I want some of
that and now we're out of the
philosophical theoretical realm we're in
the practicum which is where really the
magic happens so the Eternal Present
Moment The Sweet Spot of the generous
present moment is the place we create
from and when we are when we're there we
disconnect from our bodies we become
nobody
we disconnect from people in our lives
we're not thinking about our ex or our
boss we are no one we're not thinking
about our cell phone our computer we are
no thing we are not thinking about where
we live where we work where we sleep we
are nowhere and we're not thinking about
the predictable future and the familiar
past we're in no time and when you're
disconnecting or dissociating from
everything known you're in the unknown
and that's where the magic happens rule
number two believe in yourself I
consider myself a pretty open-minded
person I mean I have a pretty good
meter too like I I have a
transmitter that like I just I'm a I'm a
practical person yeah I want to talk
about Quantum superimposition if it
doesn't change my life in any way I want
to know how it's going to affect my life
I'm a pragmatist so I consider myself a
pretty open-minded person but I have you
know I'm skeptical about things because
I want to challenge them
in a way that I think it really helps
people right so
when I saw you know some of the dramatic
changes take place
I was I I I I I never thought in my
lifetime
that I would be witnessing what I'm in
what I witness and every single
week-long event that we've done and
we've done 30 of them now
and it's never been a disappointment
there's just a transformative thing that
takes place that is way bigger than me
so when you see a person with a stroke
who's blind in the quarter of their
Vision or has paralysis and can't move
an arm
and you see that Vision completely
restored and then you see the scan that
shows there's no longer any blemish or
damage to the visual field
you just you can't go back
to business as usual you can't go back
to being the same person you once you
know
you can't not know and and and it's so
beautiful because
Consciousness is awareness and awareness
is noticing and paying attention
so when you see a person who has a
transformation and you see the science
that says in a week-long event
there'll be over 600 metabolic changes
in 75 percent of the audience for the
better in a one-week event
when you when you know that
you're now you're aware of another
possibility that may not be the
possibility that we think is free will
to choose from gnomes this is now you're
stepping outside
and when a person shows up and believes
in themselves and does the work
they're believing in possibility you
cannot believe in possibility
and and and believe in yourself not
believe in yourself you got to believe
in yourself and believe in possibility
you got to believe in possibility you
got to believe in yourself so
for me personally I I it's way bigger
than me I'm very humbled on a regular
basis every time I get another
testimonial
uh I say this person is speaking the
truth and and it's it's a footprint
for somebody else to step into and
I think the world needs that more than
ever so for me
um
my greatest passion my greatest joy I
think there's some there's something in
US Glenn that's so empathetic uh now
we're we have universities that are
studying we're studying people that can
be healed remotely you don't even need
to be in their presence if you
understand the science of quantum
physics and you understand how to do it
you could hit a Target
and heal another person at a distance
and there it is and there it's gone
now when you see that occur
there's some kind of empathy I I drop in
on the calls of these people that show
up every single day of their life to
heal another person and they do at least
three or four a day
and these people they're not doing it
because they want to be a Healer
they're doing it because well how they
feel when they see a mother who's
comes on the zoom call and says my
daughter was you know a handicapped from
birth she had a traumatic birth she's
listless unresponsive never looked at
her brothers and all of a sudden this
kid is smiling at her brothers and
trying to talk and you watch the
people on the zoom call that are the
healers you see everywhere all in tears
there's this empathy that takes place
where we're contributing as a species to
one another that we were part of
somebody's transformation we gave in
some way another one of us is better in
this kind of feeling of empathy this
feeling of connection is so profound
that goes against all those survival and
stress emotions that create Division and
polarity and separation and and distrust
and and so
that's when Community starts coming
together that's when we start to
collaborate cooperate and it and it's
got to be from the heart so
I'm super hopeful about
um well what what we're doing rule
number three aim for real change the
greatest challenge uh when we have uh
strong emotions that are stored in the
brain and body is it's very difficult
uh to think greater than how we feel
that I think that is the challenge and
uh feelings uh are a record of the past
so so
the person if they can't think greater
than how they feel then they can't see a
possible future
because they're looking at that future
through the lens of their past biology
and so
the best thing for a person to do if
they're truly truly committed to change
is to really understand what change
means
and really understand that there's a
biology and a very specific explanation
of what change is okay so the person
says I didn't create this reality okay
okay you didn't create that reality I
didn't ask for the life that I'm living
okay you didn't ask for the life that
you're living okay
[Music]
um
I didn't pick these parents somehow I
was born into this family okay great
so now what
I mean now whatever I mean like if our
excuse to change is really it's that
person or that circumstance or that past
that's really making me feel this way
you can do that for a while
but if you start reading and learning
and filling your brain with knowledge
and making new Connections in your brain
you got more raw materials to start
thinking about new possibilities now
that's what information does information
every time you learn something new
you're making thousands of synaptic
Connections in your brain repeat it
review it think about it talk about it
share it and those circuits begin to
create long-term connections called
Memories and now you're adding more
three-dimensional stitches into the
tapestry of your gray matter and and
you're building information to see that
there are other ways to live now
pick up a book on someone who's had
trauma and they turn that trauma around
and they live their life in joy and then
and they see it differently and you're
picking up and relating with the story
and at the same time you're realizing
you're identifying with this character
and if they can do it you can do it too
all right so now the possibility exists
okay
now the person really who truly wants to
be happy says I can't I can't live in my
past any longer okay I understand that I
know it's hard and I'm gonna I'm gonna
default back to my old personality maybe
10 times or 20 times or 100 times in one
day
that's okay because if I'm alive
tomorrow I'm gonna try and do it better
the next day I'm not gonna think act and
feel this way so how many times do we
have to forget
until we really stop forgetting and
start remembering how many times do we
go unconscious in our waking day that we
have to stop going unconscious and stay
conscious
so the person who no longer wants to be
and I hate to use this word victimized
by their life but
excusing themselves from the possibility
that there could be an alternative way
to live a new life to live in the person
who excuses themselves that way is
because they can't imagine a new life
greater than how they typically feel and
of course it takes trauma or disease or
diagnosis or loss or betrayal
or the person to be so knocked out of
balance that they finally say I have to
change
and they can tell you exactly where they
were the time of day it was who they
were with when they made up their mind
to change this happens thousands of
times in our research the person says
I'm making up my mind in this moment and
they make a decision with such firm
intention
that the amplitude of that decision
carries a level of energy that causes
their body to respond to their mind
that the choice that they're making in
that moment in time is a moment in time
they will never forget
in other words the stronger the emotion
they felt when they made that choice
independent of what was going on in
their environment and their life the
more they'll remember the choice they're
making that's what emotions do and that
gives the body a sampling or a taste of
the future they're changing their state
of being in one instant rule number four
get along with others there's a biology
to personal change and transformation so
we have this emerging youth that that
has to resolve
the problems that have been created by
this past generation from a greater
level of Consciousness and that means
when everybody else is angry and
everybody else is frustrated you're
gonna have to show compassion
when everybody else is fearful and
worried you're gonna have to show
courage when everybody else is racing
and rushing and competing to succeed and
climbing over each other to get to the
top you're gonna have to learn how to be
in the present moment and draw to you
and I think if you do that in the
beginning
it feels unnatural because everybody
else is doing something else
but how do we become Supernatural unless
we start doing the things that feel
unnatural so anger is not going to
resolve it that's actually what's
created Prejudice is not going to
resolve it that's what's created it
greed is not going to resolve it that's
what exactly actually has created it and
so
we're in a time right now right before
our eyes we're watching the world in
many ways that experience such extreme
polarity
that the wobbling of polarity is
breaking the system right and it's
creating chaos is disorder chaos is the
no longer the known as we're in a big
unknown right now
so when there's brain and heart
coherence God we have such incredible
data that could take if I trained you on
how to do that you could be running
around doing a thousand different things
and I could say Emilio sit down you got
15 minutes uh to synchronize your heart
to your brain we do this all the time
and whether the young guys running
around chasing this one-year-old
two-year-old kid one of my staff is
running around doing a thousand
different things sit down
they sit down and all of a sudden music
starts and you see them start moving in
and all of a sudden you see this
beautiful low frequency take place in
the heart and once we see that it starts
to build you see the parasympathetic
nervous system go up which means these
are relaxing and then the
parasympathetic nervous system goes down
and the sympathetic nervous system goes
up
and all of a sudden the brain moves into
those gamma patterns and that person
yeah the heart is informing the brain
the heart is telling the brain it's safe
to create the heart is giving the brain
information we actually see this now the
brain the heart has Intelligence brain
thinks but the heart knows so all of a
sudden the heart says Emilio is time to
create you're out of survival and you
get these incredible ideas you get the
mystical moment you get the
understanding you get the download you
get whatever that is people can do that
now on command now why is that important
because you know most people are
stressed
in survival and unconscious in a program
and racing and rushing to try to make
that feeling of emptiness or pain go
away and there's and they're lost in the
illusion of Separation thinking they
need the outer environment to do it
chaos is happening you got to be the eye
of the storm you got to be relaxed and
out of survival and awake and heart and
brain coherence means relaxed and awake
so then we take our youth we're
investing in our youth right now because
they're going to be the leaders of our
future
we want to teach them what leadership
truly is from the heart we want to teach
them how to make changes that are
permanent we want them to consider the
whole we want them to come up with ideas
that we will be interested in supporting
and backing that will create that kind
of cultural change that takes place and
most importantly
that they get along with one another I
mean why can't we just get along with
each other take away all the
all the governments take away all all
the different cultures and you see
people in my you see modern events a
thousand people 2 000 people all Races
all all cultures we all get along
everybody loves everybody I mean that's
that's who we innately are also to make
sure you're actually taking action after
watching this video I've designed a
special free worksheet just for this
video the worksheet will highlight all
the Lessons Learned in this video as
well as pull out our three favorite
learnings and quotes that will inspire
you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there rule number five Define your
vision of the future that's how powerful
we are you could actually like the story
We Tell ourselves
is how we perceive the world
and so then then when we create the
difficulties in our life it reaffirms
the belief that life is hard that it's
really someone out there that's doing it
to us that it's a circumstance in the
past that created this okay let's take
away the person that did it let's shoot
him to the Moon Let's uh let's erase
your past now what are you going to do
now I am you still you still got to do
something right you're still alive and
I say we already know how to do this
we already know how to do this we're
wired to be creators we're wired to do
this the thing that stops us for the
most part in doing it is really the
hormones of stress because living in
stress constantly is living in survival
and living in survivals living in
emergency in an emergency it's not a
time to create an emergency it's not a
time to open your heart it's not a time
to learn
it's not even a time to sit still
so most people then that are living in
stress and living in survival they can't
believe in a future yet because it's not
a time to create so getting people to
that point
where they make up their mind and they
make up their mind enough to begin to
think there's got to be a better way
there's got to be something else
that Awakening process typically happens
when people reach their lowest
denominator
they hit rock bottom because then they
can see themselves Through The Eyes of
somebody else you're you feel so altered
you're not returning any text you feel
so altered you want to go to dinner with
your buddies you feel so altered you
know you don't want to watch your
favorite TV show you're just you're just
disconnected and that's when you start
observing yourself
but my message is why wait for that I
mean you can learn and change in pain
and suffering or you can learn and
change enjoy an inspiration if you're
waking up every morning being defined by
a vision of the future instead of the
memories of the past and you get up and
you're inspired from an elevated self
now instead of a limited self you could
observe the old cell from an elevated
State instead of that diminished State
and people are doing that so they are
aware
of those thoughts and yes it takes uh
effort and if it was easy everybody
would be doing it but just because you
have a thought doesn't necessarily mean
it's true and when you start looking and
observing those thoughts
um I think you are like Gandalf because
Gandalf also said you know you may not
pass you know when he meant like that's
kind of severity when it comes to how we
we make up our mind about things that's
the kind of energy or intention
begins to create the biggest volume of
change in our life and I've interviewed
thousands of people in our work that
have
healed from really serious health
conditions and I would say about 90 of
them when I asked them so what happened
the first thing they say all the time is
I just made up my mind I just made up my
mind I was going to do this and they
made a decision
with such firm intention that the
amplitude of that decision
carried a level of energy that was
greater than the hardwired programs in
their brain and the emotional
conditioning in their body and the
choice that they made caused their body
to respond to a new mind in fact the
choice they made became a moment that
they would never forget it was an event
and the stronger the emotion they felt
the more they paid attention to the
choice and in a sense they were
remembering their future and the body
emotionally was getting a sampling a
taste of the future and they're lying to
that future and
that's when the body's healing began
that's when the miracle started right in
that moment that's how powerful really
are now what if you did that every day
what if you made up your mind every
single day you weren't going to get up
from your meditation until you were that
person you wanted to be game on now
because you'd have to do battle
with all the things that are not
consistent with it and that's exactly
how our brain works so then if you want
to be wealthy you can't feel lack
you want to be a master you can't judge
your co-worker you want to be like
somebody great in history then you
better execute peace in every area of
your life that's that's the law so
you take the prayer out on the road now
you take the prayer you're the living
example of the prayer that's where
that's where it matters the most and
that's when people start getting
suspicious and say Sean man you change
your medication I mean you're looking
way too happy all of a sudden well
you're not relying on anything outside
of you to bring you Joy you're you're
you're overcoming yourself every day and
people say to me well why do you do your
meditations in the morning I always say
easy because if I can overcome myself at
the beginning of the day the rest of the
day is easy right because that's the
biggest that's the biggest Master right
is the self rule number six don't stress
yourself out living in stress is living
in survival and survival is a very
primitive mechanism that allows us to
really really adapt to an environment
that's threatening or dangerous the
moment you perceive a danger or threat
you switch on an autonomic function in
your body the sympathetic nervous system
and there's an arousal
the arousal of those hormones causes a
heightening of the senses because now we
want to become more acute that there's a
danger there if there's a if there's a
a tiger in the bushes and you hear
something rumbling around in its night
you're going to either run fight or
freeze or hide that's your choices and
so that works really well in survival
for the short term because the arousal
causes us feeling like we're more our
body we get a rush of energy the arousal
causes our brain waves to change and to
move into a more alert state
we now are focused on what it is in the
environment we're giving it our
attention all of our attention and now
we're trying to predict what's going to
happen in the future based on what we've
known in the past so we're overlaying a
known into the future so that we can
prepare and normally when we don't know
what it is
the unknown causes us to feel these
primitive emotions of survival and it's
best to run it's best to fear the
unknown so
the challenge becomes
that that works really well for the
short term
but when you switch on this system and
you're mobilizing enormous amounts of
the body's energy and resources for some
threat in your outer world there's no
energy in your inner world for growth
and repair there's no energy for
long-term building projects and we start
tapping the body's vital resources and
that's what creates mental health or
physical health or spiritual disease
right so because no organism can live in
that emergency state for that extended
period of time
it's like
there's a hurricane coming through
Australia you're not going to be
thinking about remodeling your kitchen
at that time it's not a time for
long-term projects right so now when
we're in stress and we're in survival
the self is the most important you don't
trust it's not a time to love it's not a
time to learn it's not a time to
communicate uh it's not a time to be
vulnerable it's not a time to open your
heart it's not the time to sit down and
close your eyes and go within you would
be eaten the survival Gene is switched
on
when people spend 70 percent of their
time living in the state so then in that
state where the arousal takes place the
brain moves into a heightened brain wave
pattern called beta brainwave pattern
now as I said that's like driving your
sports car in first gear on the freeway
you it's it's the jump start but you
can't do it for a long period of time
because in stress
stress is signaled by the loss of
control not being able to predict the
next moment the unknown or the
perception that something's going to get
worse and when you're in that state you
start trying to control and predict
everything in your life and you shift
your attention from one person to
another person to another problem to
another thing to another place to
another object to a group of situations
and every one of those elements has a
neurological Network in the brain so the
arousal
causes the brain like a lightning storm
in the clouds to start firing out of
order it starts firing in coherently and
when the brain is incoherent we're
incoherent when the brain isn't working
right we're not working right so then
now the person is aroused in that state
it's never occurred to them that they
could change that
in fact they're telling you I am this
way because of my boss because of my ex
because of my past because of the news
because of the global situation whatever
it is
and what they're really saying is I'm
using something in my outer environment
to validate or Justify why I feel this
way
so then that means then they're also
going to be dependent on something in
their outer environment to make them
feel better
and whether it's a drug or a a treatment
or a whatever it is uh complaining
whatever it is that makes them feel
better and the moment they notice that
they've done something and they've used
something outside of them to make that
feeling go away they'll pay attention to
what it was and every time they feel
that feeling they'll become dependent on
it so now they're more dependent on
their environment so then the
subconscious program is when things are
good you feel good but when things are
bad you feel bad so you're completely
victim to your environment and the
environment is actually controlling the
way you feel and think
now anything that controls the way you
feel and think you're victim too so I
said Glenn why are you in such a bad
mood I'm in a bad mood because of this
person the circumstance this the
situation in my life what you're really
saying is something in my outer
environment is literally controlling my
feelings my emotions and my thoughts
so then it turns out
that when the person is in that state
and they're in that aroused State their
heart is beating because the sympathetic
nervous system switched on but they're
not running they're not fighting they're
not hiding they're stepping on the gas
pedal and they're stepping on the brake
and the Heart starts beating very
incoherently and incoherent waves in the
brain and incoherent waves in the heart
diminish energy so energy goes out of
the brain your energy goes out of the
heart we stop thinking clearly we stop
rationalizing very well we can't plan
for the future
we're uninspired in our heart we don't
trust we can't feel gratitude we can't
feel appreciation we can't feel love
it's not a time to feel any of those
things so then that's the beginning of
disease right so the person starts
thinking about their problems and they
turn on that stress response just by
thought alone and if the hormones of
stress push the genetic buttons that
create disease then your thoughts are
going to make you sick
and the question is if your thoughts can
make you sick is it possible that your
thoughts can make you well
and by the same means if you're using
every person every circumstance in your
life to reaffirm
that dependency on that Rush of emotions
then you become addicted to the life you
don't even like
that's why change is so hard because
you'd rather suffer and be in pain than
take a chance in the unknown because the
unknown you can't predict it so people
cling to the familiar and cling to the
known and and so they become dependent
on the environment so what we found out
was
is there a way to make the brain more
coherent is there a formula that we can
teach people instead of narrowing their
focus on the material world
narrowing their focus on everything
known what if they broaden their focus
and they put it on nothing on Space if
they broaden their focus and they they
open their awareness uh uh in this way
what happens to the brain and we found
the brain gets really organized what if
they traded fear for an elevated emotion
and we taught them how to start working
with their body rule number seven
control your thoughts I don't overthink
that there's a time where you're isn't
influencing your body and a time where
your body isn't influencing your mind
but from a very simplistic standpoint
when you have a thought every time you
have a thought you make a chemical
and when you fire that thought the brain
produces a chemical it signals the body
for you to begin to feel exactly the way
you were just thinking
so if you have a joyful thought you make
chemicals that make you feel Joy if you
have a self-depreciating thought it your
body switches on a different set of
circuits than the brain and produces
different chemicals and you feel
unworthy
the problem is is the moment we start
feeling unworthy the moment we start
feeling unhappy the moment we start
feeling angry the brain checks in with
the body and it causes the body causes
the mind to think the same thoughts
equal to how it's feeling so then the
person starts thinking more thoughts
equal to that feeling firing and wiring
certain networks in the brain and
setting the same to the body
so thoughts are the language of the
brain and feelings of the language of
our body and how we think and how we
feel creates our state of being so it
makes sense then that some people get
caught in these Loops of thinking and
feeling and feeling and thinking
for years on end
and the redundancy of that cycle the
thought and the feeling
an image or a memory and an emotion a
stimulus in response is what conditions
the body emotionally
like any conditioning process
to live in the past now the body is the
objective mind
it doesn't know the difference between
the real life experience that's creating
that emotion and the emotion that the
person is fabricating by thought alone
so most emotions are chemical records of
the past
so the person by living by the same
emotional state
their body leaving us in the same past
experience
24 hours a day seven days a week and 365
days a year to the body the body is
literally emotionally conditioned into
the past
Well
turns out that
certain thoughts that we think that
produce certain chemicals either cause
the body to flourish
and to grow and certain thoughts cause
it to weaken and the response then
causes the body to move out of balance
now here's an example in the short story
we all know that when we are threatened
or there's some danger in our outer
world where we feel like we lost control
of something and we can't predict what's
going to happen next or we have the
constant perception that things in our
life are going to get worse we turn on a
very primitive system an alarm system an
emergency system that says that there's
a threat and a danger
and what happens is the body mobilizes
enormous amounts of energy and chemicals
to prepare us for that danger or threat
well that's sympathetic response and for
the short term
all organisms in nature can tolerate
short-term stress
the problem is is that when there's that
arousal of chemicals that's created the
person becomes
conditioned or needs the rush of that
adrenaline the rush of that chemical to
feel something
so if you start responding to the people
in your life or the circumstances in
your life and the conditions in your
life and your response is producing that
emergency system
then over time when your pupils dilate
and your salivary juices shut down and
blood is sent to your extremities and
your heart rate increases and
respiratory rate increases your body's
prepared for that danger but what if
you're sitting in traffic
what if you're sitting next to an in-law
what if you're sitting next to a
co-worker in a cubicle or watching the
news
so what happens is is that our response
to the environment
the arousal causes us to pay more
attention to our problems
and this is where it gets dangerous
because we can think about our problems
and we can turn on that same stress
response just by thought alone now
stress is when your brain and body are
knocked out of homeostasis is when
you're knocked out of balance you keep
knocking the body out of balance
that imbalance becomes the new balance
and now the person's headed for disease
because no one can live in emergency
mode in that state where you're putting
all your attention on your outer world
there's no energy for growth and repair
in your inner World Okay so
it's a scientific fact that the hormones
of stress push the genetic buttons long
term and create disease well if you can
turn on the stress response just by
thought alone thinking about your
problems
that means that your thoughts can
literally make you sick
so the question is if your thoughts
could make you sick
is it possible that your thoughts can
make you well and we have spent over 10
years of studying this mind-body
connection and the mind and the body are
always talking to each other rule number
eight change your frequency in this
realm called space-time this
three-dimensional reality
if you just look at the science behind
space-time there's an infinite amount of
space space is eternal there's no end of
space right and I as I said we
experience time
moving through space
and we got to play by the rules of
classical Newtonian physics and the way
that we create in three-dimensional
reality is that you see someone that's
got the nice sports car and you don't
have it and the moment you experience
lack that you don't have it but you want
it then the lack says I got to get busy
getting that which is social media yeah
everything yeah yeah to keep you
consuming to keep you and keep you
interested right so there's nothing
wrong with that
um well I found that when people really
do take
from someone to no one from something to
nothing from somewhere to Nowhere from
some time to no time there are dramatic
changes that take place in the brain and
body dramatic levels of order we start
to see there's a level of coherence a
synchronization that takes place in the
nervous system
now if they do that properly then we
could say then if you're not sure a body
if you're not you're anything you're
identifying with in your environment and
you're not thinking about time well who
are you your Consciousness you're aware
of nothing you're in this void right in
this vacuum
now that realm that you pass into this
fertile as I said with frequency with
with information every thought has a
frequency there
in this realm called time space it's
inverse the space time the rules are
completely different if there's nothing
visible it's frequency it's energy it's
vibration it's it's thought it's
Consciousness it's information
and connection everything is connected
there's no separation it's Unity it's
wholeness it's Oneness
everything's connected to everything
else now you got to change your you got
to change your the way you think when
you get to this place so now in time
space there's an infinite amount of time
instead of instead of space being
Eternal time is eternal so there's so
there's one infinite Present Moment One
Eternal now okay now let's think about
that
if you had all the time in the world
to get things done how many things could
you get done
in imagination yeah equal to your
imagination well that's the quantum
there's infinite possibilities actually
of all the time right
so in the realm of space-time
we move through space from one point to
another and if we want to get there
sooner we move faster
we drive fast we run faster we do things
faster if we want to get there harder to
yeah we work harder right you got to
work you gotta fight for it right in
this realm there's nowhere to go there's
no space so you're connected to
everything so here's the here's the
dichotomy the way that we change
our movement Through Time spaces to
change the thought or the frequency
and every past present and future
possibility is all existing
in the present moment and that's a big
one for people to wrap their mind around
so there are dimensions we can move
through times we can travel through
times to travel in a mystical moment
to a childhood memory that defined you
and you can see yourself as your adult
self and have compassion for that child
and get the understanding that that
child didn't have at that time and it'll
change your biology in a second the
person who because you're connected to
that person you are that past you are it
but you're not seeing it as the
seven-year-old child you're seeing it as
an integrated adult called Emilio saying
God I love that kid that's not the truth
he just saw it that way it wasn't his
fault he wasn't responsible for that oh
my God and now
somehow the memory is replaced from a
greater level of Consciousness the
person who has been abused physically
sexually emotionally
who has Suicidal Tendencies severe
depression
anxiety and and
panic attacks endometriosis a weird
hormonal things all because of
molestation and abuse in the past
in the present moment they can they can
see their past
from a greater level of Consciousness
and have such a moment of pure love
that they don't want to change anything
in their past they think it's perfect
for them now because it brought them to
that moment of ecstasy that moment of
Freedom now
as you change your thought or your
frequency you can move forward in time
too and in forward in time there's an
infinite number of possible use
that also exist as potentials
so when a person has a mystical moment
they're actually accessing information
from the field that's very relevant to
them rule number nine meditate the word
meditation means to become familiar with
that's exactly what that symbol means
familiarization so if you're sitting in
your meditation and your brain is going
you can't quit it's too hard you're
becoming familiar with those thoughts
that's a meditation there's no such
thing as a bad meditation there's just
overcoming yourself you're sitting there
and your body wants to get up and do
things and check your email and check
your texts and you become aware that
it's doing that you become familiar with
that you're in a meditation if you're
realizing that you're angry and
frustrated and resentful and all you're
doing is sitting there that's in there
now you're becoming familiar with that
old self that's a good thing and if you
start saying what thoughts do I want to
fire and wire in my brain and you keep
firing and wiring them you're going to
become familiar with those you start
reviewing who you're going to be when
you open your eyes and you keep
reviewing it keep reviewing it reviewing
it you keep firing and wiring it's going
to become familiar to you and if you
trade resentment and impatience for
gratitude and freedom and joy you start
making those chemicals
in your meditation every single day I
swear to you you'll get familiar with
that so the process of change is
unlearning and relearning it is breaking
the habit of the old self and
Reinventing a new self and we use
meditation
as a way to change our brain and body to
be different be greater than the
environment be greater than our our
emotions and and habits and be and be
greater than the particular future in
the familiar past so meditation is a way
then to get us in the right State of
Mind and Body so when we present
ourselves to the world
or a better expression of it and then
practicing and staying aware your entire
day so that so that you can actually
Master something about yourself now
what's the what's the side effect of
that
you're more in love with you because you
overcame you you're and as you overcome
and you overcome and you keep overcoming
you're going to become somebody else
and in so
the beauty behind that is then your life
begins to change in really mysterious
and unusual ways and people say oh my
God I was so happy I forgot about my
back pain or my neck pain or I forgot
about my food allergies or whatever
people are dealing with it something
biologically shifts in them
and they're Freer they're more whole
they're less separate you know they feel
more pleased and and satisfied with
themselves and they really don't care
what people think of them and they
really stop judging other people because
they're they're not judging themselves
any longer so
so you could only talk around these
Concepts you really have to really apply
them to really begin to see the fruits
of your efforts
but um common people around the world
are doing The Uncommon because of it and
Rule Number 10 the last one before some
very special bonus Clips is lead by
example first of all you know mothering
is the I as I said is the hardest job in
the world in
there's I raised three kids uh three
children and I practiced uh raising them
within many of these principles
and it was children
uh number one thing is they have mirror
neurons and mirror neurons are called
empathy neurons they they Model Behavior
when a lioness is teaching her Cubs how
to hunt she's not on a chalkboard and
saying you go here you go there she's
saying watch me do this
and when the Cubs watch the Lioness hunt
as they're looking at their mom hunting
they're priming the very circuits in
their brain to hunt as they as they
watch their mom they're becoming their
mom hunting
and the the the mother's Act is
selecting and instructing circuitry in
their brain equal to the environment
that they're perceiving so
what does that mean to an adult or a
human being you got to be the example of
everything you want your children to be
that's that's the fast path to
Enlightenment so you can't tell your
kids get off your technology while
you're over there on the computer or on
the phone or on the TV and expect them
to find something to do if you're not
engaging
um
it's important to have technology but
it's also important to not have
technology and and that's healthy as
well so one of the cool things that's
happened in our our community
is we have
hundreds and hundreds and hundreds and
hundreds of kids that come to our
week-long events from the age of seven
or six all the way up to you know 25 and
26 and sometimes there's 200 on the
stage and the children are interested in
understanding that they can create a
better life and so there's certain
principles I think that really help
parents
and of course another one is never try
to reason
with your children when they're
emotional
because we don't want to be reasoned
with when we're emotional we want to be
left alone until we get through the
emotion because no information could
actually enter their brain that isn't
equal to that emotional state now
one of the most important things that I
think you can teach a child by
demonstration as as well as story
allegory and conversation is to teach
them how to shorten the refractory
period of their emotional responses
so as I said you react to or respond to
something or some condition in your
outer world uh that changes your
emotional state it could create fear it
could create anger create jealousy
hostility Envy whatever
and so then the re the lingering of that
emotion that chemical if you allow it to
last for days to weeks
it's called a mood
if it lasts for weeks and weeks uh two
months on end that's called a
temperament oh he's an angry temperament
why are you angry I'm angry because of
this experience if you keep the same
emotion going on for years on end that's
called a personality personality trait
so personality traits many times are
created by the experiences and the
emotions that
that keep us connected to the Past
teaching children how to shorten their
emotional reactions
is such such so vitally important
because when we're in that emotional
state there's a gap between the way
things appear and the way things really
are we're altered we're not ourselves
and if we act during that time if we
send an email during that time if we
speak during that time even if we think
during that time
and we follow through we'll normally say
I should have never said that I never
should have never thought that I'd never
sort of sent that email I should never
done it
so children then are so neuroplastic
it's so important
for you to have conversations with them
about how hard it is to overcome our
emotional states when we're in the
emotional state as an example my with my
daughter my my kids
whenever I saw her react to someone or
something whatever I was doing as long
as there was no injury or no one was in
danger I would stop and I'd turn around
and I would observe her just for a
minute while she was doing what she was
reacting to and she became aware that I
was observing her
after she became aware that I was
observing her then I would deal with it
however I had to deal with it
at the end of the day
I would lay down with my children in bed
and I would start to talk about myself
God I had a pretty tough day today
I lost it right around three o'clock I
couldn't get back the entire day I was
frustrated and I was impatient had too
many things going on I was overwhelmed
and I wasn't present with you guys at
dinner
I don't know making something up
if you just pause for a moment
my daughter would say yeah I got really
angry at Paris today and I'd say I know
I saw you
and I and then she'd say yeah if you
start telling me what happened I'd say
okay now that you know what happened if
it happened again
how would you do it differently how
would you behave differently how would
you evolve your experience and then we
would talk about it between her and I we
would come up with another plan another
rehearsal we would begin to okay let's
let's Okay so parents comes in she says
and you do this and said and so you're
before you go to bed at night and your
subconscious mind is wide open to
information
and so I would rehearse it with her
before she would go to sleep well you
know while the everybody was in bed and
I would then tell a story of these kids
that lived in a Faraway land and then I
would bring in each kid's little
allegory about them and what they were
working on changing to
to give them an opportunity that they
could evolve their experience
meditation the actual translation of the
word meditation means to become familiar
with so the first thing you have to do
is you have to become conscious of your
unconscious thoughts you got to notice
your automatic habits and behaviors and
you have to become aware of your
emotions that keep you anchored to the
past and if you can become so conscious
of the one unconscious states of mind
and body that they would never slip by
your conscious awareness again you're
becoming familiar with the old self so
you don't return then if you begin to
think about new ways of being being
defined by a vision
plan your behaviors review them in your
mind now if you keep doing that over and
over again nerve cells that fire
together wire together you begin to
become familiar with a new state of mind
at the same time if you can emotionally
cultivate your inspiration your joy Your
Enthusiasm ahead of the experience by
repeating that over and over again
cultivating that state it's going to
begin to become familiar to you so then
the process of change then requires
unlearning and relearning breaking the
habit of the old self Reinventing a new
self
pruning synaptic connections as we say
in neuroscience and sprouting new
connections unmerizing emotions that are
stored in the body then here's the key
reconditioning the body to a new mind
into a new emotion it's literally moving
from your past to your future it's
losing your mind and creating a new one
and so then when you begin to understand
that in the in that process it's going
to feel a little bit unfamiliar
uncomfortable and if you can relax into
that instead of going back to the past
continuously invest in your future
sooner or later it'll begin to become
easier and easier and easier and all of
a sudden when you least expect it
something amazing is going to happen in
your life and when that event begins to
occur you're going to pay attention to
what you did inside of you now to
produce the effect outside of you and
that's called human empowerment and
there isn't a person in the world that's
excluded from this equation we had a guy
that we came in a wheelchair an event we
did recently
it came in that Throne he walked from he
had ALS he walked from the back of the
room all the way to the stage walked up
the stairs out of that wheelchair on his
own I asked him he said I just I just
have to work on staying in this
emotional state because the longer I
stay there the more I'm noticing that my
body's responding he's not saying why am
I why am I not healed he understands
that the only way he can actually heal
is to change him right and so now it
becomes very practical right it becomes
very practical you think it's important
that practical part of it I think
sometimes people think they're
disqualified if they can't explain
something they do well let me tell you
one of the interesting things on the
show many of the people that do things
exceptionally well that have been on my
show athletes or entertainers
really don't do a very good job of
explaining it yeah they embody it and I
think sometimes someone listens to
somebody like you who can explain this
and think that they're disqualified from
becoming good if they can't explain how
they're doing it but the truth is it's a
repeated experience that becomes
familiar for them without the need to
express how they're doing it right right
and for me right this is your this is
your life is teaching people to do this
and giving them the tools but for the
vast majority of people it's it's
creating the experience everybody
everybody has done this at least once in
their life what did they did they sat
down and they said what would it be like
to be happy what would it be like to be
healthy what would it be like to have a
new life what would we like to be in
love and they ask the question instead
of getting on their cell phone and
texting someone or posting they actually
sat there and they actually said let me
answer the question yeah let me get
uncomfortable here and what is it that I
truly want what would I have to change
about myself to be healthy to be happy
to be well successful what are my bad
habits they get busy writing down
all the the the choices they want to
make all the things they want to do they
start writing down all their goals all
their experiences and every goal or
experience they write down in their
future there's an emotion they get
inspired they get optimistic they get
grateful they get energized and those
emotions fuel more thoughts and now
they're they're they're actually
changing their biology and then they do
something really really really really
really important
they start looking at the thoughts that
they no longer want to think they write
them down I can't it's too hard I'll
start tomorrow I don't feel good until
they start looking at the choices
they're going to have to stop making and
when they they understand when they stop
making those choices it's going to be
uncomfortable that's the hardest part
about change they start thinking about
the things they have to stop doing I
gotta get off the couch I got to stop
watching this I gotta stop over reading
whatever it is and then we've all done
this
and there comes a moment where you start
noticing that like you start saying hey
I believe this is this is actually going
to happen right and that's when you take
the foot off the gas pedal and you start
really realizing wow I was the resource
of actually making this happen and I
changed yeah I changed in the process so
the the exciting part about it you talk
people who created wealth who talk to
people who created relationships that
are talk to people who have created
Health they'll tell you my disease
my poverty was my greatest teacher my
past was my greatest teacher they look
back at their past and now there's no
longer an emotion associated with it the
memory without the emotional charges
wisdom now you get to go to the Future
you get to create whatever you're free
willed you you could be anybody you want
to be in the process I think one of the
most important things when we lose sight
of our vision is to make time for
ourselves and I think that when you
invest in yourself you invest in your
future
disconnecting from people in your life
and places that you have to go and
things that you do or things that you
own long enough to begin to reignite a
vision of how you see yourself or how
you see your future and begin to
emotionally Embrace that future and
change your state of being allows us to
see a whole new landscape if you've lost
sight of your vision take a moment and
remember that vision and begin to
emotionally embrace it and from that
state of being start to think about the
things you want to do the choices you
want to mix write them down review the
behaviors that you have to demonstrate
your goals and experiences and how it's
going to feel when you do that enough
times you're changing your brain
neurologically and you're changing your
body genetically write down the
unconscious thoughts that you have to
stay conscious of become aware of the
choices that you no longer need to make
review the behaviors and habits you have
to change about yourself and become so
conscious of them that you won't go
unconscious at all during your day
remember the experiences in your
environment that you need to stay away
from whether it's a person or a thing
just for a period of time
so that you can keep that Vision alive
and most importantly review those
emotions that keep you connected to the
past and become so conscious of them and
name them when you feel that feeling
that if it's guilt or sadness or pain
the moment you start feeling it and you
become conscious of it that's when you
can begin to change and if you keep
doing this over and over again the
unlearning and the relearning the
breaking the habit of the old self and
Reinventing a new self is going to cause
you to arrive at a whole new future and
when you do this could become your new
habit it's so important for people to
remember that they're the creators of
their lives instead of the victim of
their life the victim is saying I'm
feeling this way because that person
that circumstance or I don't have any
money is causing me to feel this way
this is my relationship with money what
that really means is I'm using my lack
to reaffirm my dependency my addiction
my conditioning that's my relationship
with money is that I put my attention on
money because I don't have it the
relationship with money is of course
built on lack and so when they don't
have it they feel bad and what they're
really saying is my outer environment my
reality is actually controlling the way
I feel and the way I think so this is
why are you in a good mood today things
are going good why in a bad mood things
are going bad today so the sun conscious
program victimization is saying that
we're allowing our environment to
influence the way we feel and the way we
think isn't that what victimization is
and the stronger the emotion we have to
our lack the more we put our attention
on the fact that we don't have it right
so then the person has forgotten that
they're creating reality because what
they're creating is lack and they're
creating more of it and they try harder
and they force harder so the experiment
then is let's try it another way let's
create from the field instead of from
matter relaxing the heart and energy
moves right in the brain we've measure
this thousand times and all of a sudden
the person moves into these beautiful
elegant brainwave states where they're
super creative right the longer you're
conscious of that energy the more you
draw that future to you so then what is
the synchronicity mean it means whatever
you're doing inside of you is producing
that effect outside of you pay attention
to what you did it again so generate put
more abundance just do it for an
experiment now when the synchronicity
happens do you think you feel suffering
or do you think you feel a little
excitement you feel inspired right so
then that synchronicity is saying use
this energy use this feeling it should
be easier for you to feel this now and
go back and do it again let's keep the
experiment going
and here comes the promotion here comes
the here comes the email here comes the
person you meet at the right time right
well we have something happening here
and then that that becomes the momentum
right
so then we generate abundance that's
that's how we do it and the relationship
just happen by accident we generate we
generate abundance right so then if you
have an hour meditation where you're
tuning into your abundant future
but then you're spending the other 15
hours a day in lack don't expect
anything to change you defaulted and
you're back to the old energy and if you
say it's that person or that
circumstance or that bank account I'm
going to say you're back to the
unconscious program being a victim right
and so then so then
so then let's go a step further
if your personality creates your
personal reality and it does and your
personality is made up of how you think
how you act and how you feel then the
present personality who's listening to
this podcast has created the present
personal reality called their life
nothing big there which means if you
want to change your personal reality
you're going to have to change your
personality right nothing changes in
your life until you change I think you
know one of the most important things is
it's so much easier to forget this
information than to remember even me you
know I have to say to myself okay Joe
dispenza what do you know and take a
moment and just sit down my cell phone
and disconnect from everything and
really have a thought like
and keep reconstructing the model in my
mind it's so important to do that
because if we understand the what and
the why and the how it gets easier then
we assign more meaning and more belief
and more intention behind it and
and if you have to say okay
okay if I'm living by these emotions
that are familiar to me that I'm
signaling the same genes in the same way
okay now I have to be conscious of not
feeling that way and you have to make a
different choice and the hardest part
about changes stop making the same
Choice as you did the day before because
the moment you decide to do something
differently and make new choices it's
going to be uncomfortable you're going
to leave the known familiar world of the
familiar emotions and thoughts and
behaviors
the body is the unconscious mind is
going to want to return back to what it
knows because we trained it that way so
it's a retraining process so if the
person says okay if I can marry a clear
intention I gotta work on getting my
brain more coherent okay they got that
in the formula that'll be a good signal
out if I can slow my brain waves down I
can learn how to do that I can get
beyond my thinking I'm a little combined
I can enter the operating system of my
autonomic nervous system program that
okay if I can combine it with an
elevated emotion really practice trading
that that suffering or that pain for
something else yeah it may take me a
little bit to feel that emotion but I
think if I keep working at it I'll begin
to change my emotional state when I feel
that emotional state I'm not going to be
thinking about the past I'm going to be
thinking about the future so so the
thought and the feeling the stimulus in
response the image and the emotion is
conditioning the body emotionally into
the future so the person says okay he
said or I read or someone else said the
environment signals the gene okay let me
write that down environment signals the
gene okay I can remember that
the end product of an experience in the
environment is the emotion okay
um if I'm feeling gratitude
and gratitude's emotional signature
means I've just received something
favorable or something wonderful just
happened to me
if I can feel the emotion of gratitude
before the event occurs
then my body would be so objective that
it's living in that future I would begin
to change my gene expression and the
stronger the emotion I feel the more I'm
going to pay attention to the picture in
my mind that I'm going to be remembering
my future my brain and body are going to
look like the event has already occurred
before it happened and if genes make
proteins and proteins are responsible
for the structure and function of my
body and the expression of proteins is
the expression of life
then I'm going to keep signaling these
I'm going to keep knocking on the door
every day and I don't care if my life is
falling apart I'm not going to fall to
that familiar emotion I'm not going to
speak the same way I'm not going to
think the same way what thoughts do I
want to fire and wire in my brain and
with intention and attention I'm going
to keep reviewing them till it becomes
an automatic thought in my head like you
can
what how am I going to be today how am I
going to be with my family I'm going to
be in traffic I'm going to be with my
co-workers how am I going to be when I'm
alone
and you start rehearsing who you're
going to be the brain in the present
moment doesn't know the difference
between the outer world or the inner
world it's the brain what it's imagining
looks real and if we're present the
brain looks like you already did it
you're priming the brain it's no longer
on record of the past now you're it's a
map to the Future you're you're in place
keep practicing that rehearsal in your
mind it's going to become automatic and
you're going to start behaving like that
person then you said
can I teach my body emotionally what
this future feels like before it happens
if you could truly open your heart and
truly feel that elevated emotion if you
kept practicing that I promise you you
would feel more of that in your day and
less of the other place and meditation
means to become familiar with and how
you think how you act and how you feel
is your personality and your personality
creates your personal reality that's the
game right so when that occurs then it's
no longer about the past and what
happened to you and the story people
tell about that they're telling a story
of their future in fact they're more in
love with their future than they are
with their past
they believe in the future more than
they believe in their past and and I
think that when we believe in ourselves
we believe in possibilities and we
believe in possibilities we have to
believe in ourselves and showing up
every day
means you must believe it's true when
you stop showing up then you don't
believe it's true any longer and and
enough people that have that kind of
conviction literally step into a new
body they step into a new a new life
they step into a new future and I I hope
um but that becomes the new normal
um and and you know research says that
Collective networks of observers
determine reality that's the latest
uh so we just got to make sure enough of
us are observing a different reality
from an elevated place of Union and
connection
instead of Separation that's that
divides communities because of survival
and stress and that's a great way to
create polarity in the world and the
union of polarity takes place in the
heart and that's where it starts it
doesn't end there it just starts there
and when I see the heart and forming the
brain I saw two students that we grabbed
one was chasing a little child around a
one and a half year old child and it was
being challenged and the other guy was
working and Staffing and running around
and we got him in the chair and we said
okay let's let's get some brain and
heart coherence and you know we had 15
20 minutes to do with these guys and you
saw them way out of balance right it's
just way out of bounds and all sudden
here comes that low frequency in the
heart boom like a big drum boom
boom all of a sudden we see that low
frequency the energy in the heart that's
only indigenous to the heart itself
starts rising and then all of a sudden
you see it rising and you see the
sympathetic nervous system rise with it
so now we know they're totally relaxed
and they're totally awake and aware the
sympathetic nervous isn't working for an
arousal when you see that kind of
connection and you see someone be able
to change that
a matter of moments my eyes say they
should be able to do that with their
eyes open at any moment it should be
such a skill and that's that's when we
we maintain our energy and our power
when you're at a greater level of
awareness everything seems to be more
connected that's what the quantum is so
you're playing at that level the
synchronicities the serendipities the
coincidences are actually informing you
that you actually are creating your life
and that's the difference between being
the victim of your life and being the
creator of your life because when the
environment is controlling the way we
feel and the way we think some person
some circumstance some condition what
does that really mean that means that
person or circumstance is actually
causing me to think and feel a certain
way and and I I don't think I have any
control of it then I must be victim to
that circumstance right and that's a
program right yeah so so I I realized in
my own Journey also that
if I don't change my response
to things in my life I'll never change
so so it's not even it's not that you
responded the question really is how
long right so when you become aware that
your environment is controlling how you
think and feel and your response changes
watch out because that now you no longer
belong to the Past
you actually belong to the Future so get
a coherent heart we know how to do that
really well get a go here and brain we
can do that really well have people take
all of their attention on off the
material world of everything known go
from a convergent Focus to a diversion
Focus we got the data to prove that if
you keep putting your attention on
nothing on Space somehow the brain gets
highly organized so now brain coherence
heart coherence you synchronize your
energy to whatever it is you want and
you got to sustain that state you can't
we've had people that have healed
themselves from Parkinson's disease from
cancers
from ALS literally remission of the
condition and then have bad news
and in one hour driving to the hospital
all of their symptoms came back after
being completely healed for two years
That's How Strong those emotions are
right so so so in your circumstance
right
I want people
I want people to have those moments
where they have to literally choose
because I think
when it's the hardest it matters the
most that's what I think so so all those
things where you're agitated with the
person having their moment you know that
could be you having your moment right
and you would want someone like that
person doesn't want to do that they're
just having their thing we may not be
able to control everything in our outer
world right but we certainly can control
our inner world and so it's not so
important to not react I mean everybody
reacts I react the question is
how long are you going to react so if
you keep an emotional reaction going on
for an extended period of time you're
memorizing that emotion and your body as
the unconscious mind is believing it's
living in the same past experience 24
hours a day seven days a week 365 days a
year the body doesn't know the
difference between the real experience
that produces the emotion and emotion
that we create by thought alone so then
the emotion then reaffirms the state and
then people start to use the problems
and the conditions in their life to keep
that emotion going and I would call that
an addiction so we become addicted to
the very life we don't even like
so it's important then for people to
realize then when you have that moment
where you have crisis or something
breaks down that you do have control
over it and it's a formula and it's a
skill and our research shows that you
can teach people how to do that and so
then when you're living by some emotion
there'll always be a gap between the way
things appear and the way things really
are emotions alter our perception and if
you act during that time you'll always
say the same thing I should have never
said that I should have never done that
I should never thought that I should
have never sent that email so then
shortening your emotional reactions
is a level of intelligence then that
causes you then to recalibrate because
most people don't think they have
control over that they'll say that
person did it to me that circumstance is
the reason I am this way then I would
say if something in your outer
environment
is controlling your thoughts and
feelings then you're a victim to your
environment and yet
how you think and feel creates your
outer world so if you're thinking and
feeling equal to everything that's known
in your present personal reality you
keep creating more of the same so to
change then is to think and feel greater
than the conditions in your environment
and be able to do that to such a degree
then you're no longer reacting to the
same people in the same way and that
takes an effort it's and it's not easy
in the beginning but once you start
practicing
uh you get better at it and just like
anything else you start to move through
your life with more coherence and you're
less likely to knee-jerk and if you're
less likely to knee jerk then you're not
in an unconscious program when you teach
people how to connect to the energy of a
future dream and be defined by a vision
of the future instead of the memories of
the past to believe in their future more
than they believe in their past
to fall in love with their future more
than they fall in love with their past
and be able to combine that clear
intention of that future
and begin to feel the emotions of that
future before it's made manifest they're
broadcasting a whole new signature into
the field now the beauty behind that is
is that the longer you're conscious of
that energy
the more you're drawing that future to
you
which also means then the moment you get
in your car and start getting angry and
getting frustrated because you're in
traffic
now you just disconnected from the
energy of your future and now you're
back to the energy of your past and
those survival emotions exert less
effects on the nature of reality so now
you feel like matter trying to change
matter you're you're separate and so you
force it you control it you try harder
you wish you pray you hope I mean hope
is a beggar we do everything compete to
try to manipulate and make it happen
because we have limited resources then
so then when a person is able to sustain
or maintain that modified state of mind
and being
then the fun starts to happen because
you start seeing those synchronicities
you start seeing those coincidences
those opportunities those unknowns those
things start falling out of nowhere
because you are connected to that field
of information and not only are you
connected to it but you're also
beginning to influence it so then more
and more people are creating now
and less of less people are experiencing
the state of being called being a victim
so then if you're a victim then you
would say I was angry because of traffic
well then I would say to you well you
mean your outer world was controlling
how you think and feel some circumstance
some person something in your outer
world is actually controlling your
feelings and thoughts that means you're
a victim to those circumstances but when
you change the way you think and feel
and it starts to produce effects in your
outer world now you start to realize
you're the creator of your life and the
moment you start seeing feedback in your
life
you're going to pay attention to what
you did and you're going to do it again
and now you're going to believe now
you're more of the creator of your life
and less of the victim of your life
don't expect
anything in your life to change if your
environment
is controlling your feelings and
thoughts and if your environment is
controlling how you feel and think and I
say to you Aubry why are you so upset
today oh well this person's upsetting me
what you're really saying is that person
is controlling your feelings and your
thoughts and that means you're a victim
to your environments well to turn that
around and you start realizing your
feelings and thoughts create your
environment
and you start seeing the effects of you
at cause
you're going to react less to the people
in your life because you're going to
understand that you'll be back to the
victim Consciousness and and when you
start seeing that you're creating
outcomes in your life you're going to
believe more that you're the creator of
your life unless the victim of your life
and I say the more you practice it
the better you get at it you can't go to
the Future holding on to the biology of
your past decide what thoughts you can
bring to your future write them down
thoughts like I can it's too hard I'll
never change I'll start tomorrow what's
wrong with me it's someone else's fault
[Music]
hide on what behaviors or actions or
unconscious habits you have to change
how do you talk do you complain do you
blame do you make excuses do you feel
sorry for yourself just becomes so
conscious of those behaviors that you'll
never go unconscious again and lastly
you have to decide what emotions no
longer belong in your future that means
if you want to be wealthy you can take
lack if you want to be healthy you can't
take insecurity or fear you got to begin
to condition your body to a new mind if
you do this
every single day your personality
creates your personal reality and your
personality is made up of how you think
how you act and how you feel change any
one of those things and you change your
life and begin to measure the effects of
you it costs give it a shot a good way
to see that is that everybody does it
like everybody does that all the time
and they would here's the problem all of
that is fine the problem is is that
they're looking
through the lens of the past that
reality they're they're seeing they're
seeing their future through the lens of
the past they can't see possibility
because they can't think greater than
how they feel or feelings have become
the means of thinking and if you believe
that your thoughts have anything to do
with your destiny
then you're thinking in the past because
those emotions are driving your thoughts
and those emotions are the familiar
records of the past right so now so let
me just go one step further so so that
is
how people reaffirm themselves every
single day into a known identity and
let's just say the trauma or the
Betrayal or the loss or the shock or the
diagnosis was a profound moment that
created a strong emotion and that person
doesn't think
that they have any control of regulating
and changing that emotion because it's
visceral it's somatic it's real they
feel it and that disturbance that known
they'd rather cling to that pain they'd
rather cling to that that suffering the
then to take a chance and possibility to
step outside the unknown now the hardest
part
I'm getting to time by the way the
hardest part about all of this
then is not making the same choices you
did the day before
so the moment you start to realize that
you complain that you blame that you
make excuses that you feel sorry for
yourself that you judge others that you
react emotionally to your spouse to your
ex to your co-worker to traffic the
moment you become conscious that you're
doing that and you say I'm gonna stop
well the body now the servant that is
now the mind that the servant is not a
master so now the body's clinging to the
known and you say okay I'm not going to
complain I'm not going to suffer anymore
you make a different choice and the body
says well wait a second
Jonathan you've been doing that for 30
years so you just what so the body
starts influencing the mind it starts
sending signals back to the brain and
says you can't do this it's too hard
start tomorrow it's your mother's fault
it's your culture's fault it's it's this
it's your past
and if you accept believe and surrender
to that thought
as if it's true without really having a
critical analysis of it it slips right
by your conscious mind and it causes you
to make the same choice that leads to
the same behavior that will reproduce
the same experience and there you are on
the couch feeling the same emotion and
you say this feels right well no that
feels familiar right so that's that's
how people live in the gnome they live
in the past so the predictable future
then is everybody gets up in routine and
they're on autopilot and they run
through a series of automatic behaviors
and if you do that enough time a habit
is a redundant set of automatic
unconscious thoughts behaviors and
emotions that's acquired through
repetition do it enough times the body
will now know how to do it better than
the conscious mind it becomes implicit
right so now most people lose their free
will
to a set of programs and their bodies
dragging them into a predictable future
based on what they did in the past and
that predictable future is the known as
well so if the familiar past is the
known and the predictable future is the
known there's only one place left
where the unknown exists and that's
really that sweet spot of the generous
present moment and when we truly can
become relaxed and dial down
the stress hormones that cause us to
live in survival that causes us to try
to anticipate the worst case scenario
that remembers the past if we can work
with the body and be greater than the
body
to be greater than our attention on
every element in our environment and
truly labor for the present moment that
unknown which has been conditioned to
the into the human being to be a scary
place because in survival you run from
the unknown if you can teach people to
actually relax into the present moment
and relax into that place that's the
unknown that's where possibility exists
and we all do it
and getting to that elegant moment then
time tends to alter you think only 10
minutes went by about an hour and a half
went by and where were you well as your
brain waves slow down in this process
when you're in like a thinking
analytical place like we are right now
we're in these great bearing wave
patterns it's called you understand this
beta brainwave patterns but as you slow
your body down and starts moving to
Alpha time Alpha Waves tend to cause
time to seem a little bit more elongated
when you're in Theta which is when
you're half awake and you're half asleep
and you're relaxed and awake and that
level of theta time one moment seems
really long so you have an extension of
time and turns out that you can teach
people how to do this and when you do
their autonomic nervous system begins to
regulate back into order and stress is
autonomic dysregulation and all of a
sudden the person has a sense of energy
a sense of euphoria a sense of Freedom a
sense of clarity the brains we've
measured this their brains start firing
in more ordered more coherence that it
oscillates and synchronizes different
compartments of the brain or communities
of neurons are working together and you
start feeling more whole more like
yourself in the in the understanding of
yoga as an example
if you're truly really into the ACT
you forget about all your problems you
forget about all the things you got to
do you forget about what happened
yesterday breathing is away
to really change your brain waves as
we've studied this thousands of times
you slow your breathing down you slowing
your brain waves down you slow your
brain waves down you stop analyzing and
thinking when do you over analyze and
overthink when you're in high high high
beta and when's that when you're
threatened when you feel danger when
when the stress hormones are running and
we've studied the brain when this
happens and when you're analyzing your
life within that disturbing emotion I
can guarantee you you're going to make
your brain worse in fact your thought of
the problem is actually producing the
very chemistry to arouse you further out
of balance so teaching people
how to find that generous present moment
and actually relax in the unknown and
dissociate from their body dissociate
from their environment and dissociate
from time the predictable future and the
familiar past causes them for some
reason to get a reboot in in their
nervous system and they think oh God it
must have been 10 minutes and oh my God
it was it was an hour and a half that
that to me
is taking all of your attention or
disinvesting all of your attention out
of this three-dimensional reality and
that's when the door to Creation or the
mystical moment really begins to happen
for people so you ask yourself at the
end of your day I do this every day
how'd I do how'd I do today bro how'd
you do just do good where'd you fall
from grace what what what was it that
caused you to go unconscious
for the rest of the day like what was
that moment now if you're a student of
Life you'll begin to contemplate well it
was that person that said that thing
then I reacted or this I got this email
or things didn't go my way and I started
feeling angry or frustrated or fearful
the next time that happens how could I
involve my experience now you may have
to search for some answers of the best
model to build or you may actually have
a long contemplation and start to go God
the next time that happens I think I'm
gonna do this or I'm gonna do that or
I'm going to plan my behaviors and the
act of closing your eyes and rehearsing
what you're going to do
begins to install the neurological
Hardware in your brain to looks like you
already did it now the brain is no
longer a record of the past now it's a
map to the Future and if you keep
installing that Hardware the hardware
will become a software program which
means you'll just start acting like a
happy person why there's no magic there
you install the circuitry so
that's more important than the news
right it's more important than answering
any email or any text it's more
important than talking about your past
or some dinner if you can begin to just
think about how you're going to do it
differently that's the building process
neurologically already so now you have
to get conscious in order to do that and
it takes some time it means you got to
shut your cell phone off you got to
close your door you got to take a break
from everything out there and begin to
practice and so by experience then
you start noticing oh here it comes here
comes the frustration here comes the
fear and now we've given people the
tools to be able to self-regulate to
create brain and heart coherence and so
you see people say excuse me one minute
I just need a minute it takes some
breaths they get back in they connect to
the energy of their future this is
incidental compared to where they're
going so they don't fall from grace they
don't allow their energy to drop and so
yeah in the beginning it takes a lot
because it takes a lot of energy and
awareness to stay conscious and not go
unconscious but if you're persistent and
you're determined then you're sincere
you begin to figure it out you begin to
say I am not going to give my power away
to that person or that circumstance when
I can use it to heal or to create a new
future and so people then won't excuse
themselves and say I had a hard day
yesterday at a fight with my co-worker
or my ex or and I don't feel like doing
the work well that's the time they get
back on the horse yeah because because
it's the it's all of those times that we
self-correct
those are the most valuable moments thus
people who've had
profoundly transcendental experiences
where they we say got lit up they
connected and their brain goes into very
very high coherent States and super
gamma patterns that are way outside of
normal and they have a transcendental
downloader connection that's mystical
they look back at their entire life
they don't want to change one thing in
their past because it got them to that
moment that's the moment the past no
longer exists now by the same means they
look back at their past and they see all
those tough moments where they overcame
themselves and they fall in love with
that person they don't look at the good
meditations or the things that went well
they look they know that it was those
moments that got them to this moment and
I I think then that's when they begin to
understand that that all of the hard
work
all the effort in who we become makes no
one can take that away from us so then
once we arrive at that level and we
experience whatever the dream is or
whatever we create the next thing is do
it until you fully enjoy it and then
when it gets boring or predictable let's
go again let's do something else yeah
and I think that's evolution
because you made it this far in a video
I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome for 10
more amazing rules for Marissa Pierre
check the video right there next to me I
think you'll love it continue to believe
and I'll see you there I don't do no I
refuse to take no for an answer so I
want you to start to praise yourself I
want you to wake up in the morning the
first thing you go is I like myself when
there was a battle between logic